let me ask
uh the old russian overly philosophical
question about
death so we're talking about the
expanding universe
sure how do you think human civilization
will come to an end
if we avoid the uh the near-term issues
we're having
uh will it be our sun burning out will
it be comets
oh okay will it be uh what is it
oh do you think we have a shot at
reaching the
the heat death of the universe yeah so
we're gonna leave out the anthropogenic
uh nuclear policies of our potential
destruction yes which i actually think
are greater than the celestial
uh causes so uh so if we get lucky
yeah if we get an intelligent yeah yeah
so no way will we
as humans reach the heat death of the
universe i mean it's conceivable that
machines which i think will be our
evolutionary descendants
might reach that although even they will
have less and less energy with which to
work
as time progresses because eventually
even the lowest mass stars burn out
although it takes them trillions of
years to do so
so the point is is that certainly on
earth
there are other celestial threats
existential threats
comets exploding stars the sun burning
out
so we will definitely need to move away
from our
solar system to other solar systems and
then
you know the question is can they keep
on
propagating to other planetary systems
sufficiently long
in our own solar system the sun burning
out is
is not the the immediate existential
threat
that'll happen in about you know five
billion years when it becomes a red
giant
although i should hasten to add that
within the next one or two billion years
the sun will have brightened enough
that unless their compensatory
atmospheric changes
the oceans will will evaporate away you
know and you need
much less carbon dioxide for the
temperatures to be maintained roughly at
their present temperature and plants
wouldn't
like that very much so you can't lower
the carbon dioxide content too much so
so within one or two billion years
probably the oceans will evaporate away
yeah but on a sooner time scale than
that
i would say an asteroid collision
leading to a potential mass extinction
or at least an extinction of complex
beings such as ourselves
that require quite special conditions
unlike cockroaches and amoebas you know
to survive um you know one of these
civilization changing asteroids is only
one kilometer
or so in diameter and bigger and a true
mass extinction event
is 10 kilometers or larger now it's true
that we can find
and track the orbits of asteroids that
might be headed toward earth and if we
find them 50 or 100 years before they
impact us
then clever applied physicists and
engineers can figure out ways to deflect
them
but at some point you know some comet
will come in from the deep freeze of the
solar system
and there we have very little warning
months to uh to a year
what's a deep freeze sorry oh the deep
freeze is sort of out beyond
neptune there's this thing called the
kuiper belt and it consists of a bunch
of
you know dirty ice balls or icy dirt
balls it's the
source of the comets that occasionally
come close to the sun
and then there's a even bigger area
called the scattered disc which is sort
of a big donut
surrounding the solar system way out
there from which other comets come and
then there's the orc cloud
w double o rt after
uh jan ort a dutch astrophysicist and
it's the better part of a light year
away from the sun
so a good fraction of the distance to
the nearest star but that's like a
trillion or 10 trillion
comet like objects that occasionally get
disturbed by a passing star or whatever
and most of them go flying out of the
solar system but some go
toward the sun and they come in with
little warning you know by the time
we can see them they're only a year or
two
away from us and moreover not only is it
hard to
determine their trajectories
sufficiently accurately to know whether
they'll hit a tiny thing like earth
but outgassing from the comet of
um gases you know when the ices
sublimate
that outgassing can change the
trajectory just because of conservation
of momentum right it's the rocket effect
gases go out in one direction the object
moves in the other direction
and so since we can't predict how much
outgassing there will be
and in exactly what direction because
these things are tumbling and rotating
and stuff
it's hard to predict the trajectory with
sufficient accuracy to know that it will
hit
and you certainly don't want to deflect
a comet
that would have missed but you thought
it was going to hit
and end up having it hit that would be
like the ultimate charlie brown
you know goat instead of trying to be
the hero right he ended up being the
goat
you